الزلزال في السادس من فبراير كان ضخما جدا
وفي المناطق المنكوبه من الصعب على
الناجين فهم حجم ما حدث وهذا ما تحدثوا
عنه لكن لفهم ما جرى بالضبط سنتخيل ان سطح
الارض هو عباره عن احجيه عن الطبقه
الخارجيه منها ليست متصله هي مكونه من
صفائح ضخمه تقريبا عشرون عشرين قطعه
متداخله مع بعضها البعض وبنفس الشكل الذي
تتخذه الاحجيات لكنها تستمر في الحركه
وببطء وبمعدل سنتيمتر الى 20 في السنه اما
ان تتباعد او تصطدم ببعضها او تنزلق عبر
حدودها
ما احدث الزلزال الاول وما تلاه منطقيا
كان تحركا عنيفا تمزق على اثره امتداد
الصدع بين صفيحتي الاناضول والعربيه التي
تقع تركيا على خطوطه مع الصفيحه الوراثيه
ايضا تركيا تحركت مشاهدينا بثلاثه امتار
خلال ثواني نعم الجغرافيا تغيرت البلد
باكمله تحرك نحو الغرب غير او تغير مكانه